- They're like, "Hey man,
it looks like oh this is
"a bad commute.
"it's taking me a longer
time than usual I think
this morning and I'm probably late."
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone, my name is
Matt Bellassai and this
is Whine About It, a weekly
video series where I get drunk
at my desk and complain about stuff.
On this week's episode Types
of Coworkers that are the
Absolute Worst.
Let's drink.
(upbeat music)
- Because, how else am
I gonna get (bleep) up?
What, do you want me to sip it slowly?
No.
(upbeat music)
It's not chilled.
All right, first of all
there's always that one lumpy
ball sac who tries to chat it
up in the (bleep) bathroom.
I have to be around
your dusty, vanilla face
eight hours a day, five days
a (bleep) week for like ever,
for the love of god do not
talk to me while I am in
the bathroom.
Do no touch me, do not
look at me, do not (bleep)
breathe at me.
Why don't we just make
a rule, no talking to me
while anything is entering
or exiting my body.
All right, let's just make that rule.
Next, there's always that
one coworker who's always
trying to use my mug, or touches
my desk, or steals my pens.
I don't know if you
know this, but some pens
are better than other pens.
I'm sorry you chose the shit pens in life,
I chose the good pens.
You'll have to live with
your shitty decisions.
- I didn't take your pen, Matt.
- I guess my Winnie the
Pooh pen just went missing
the same day that you got a new one.
Coincidence?
No, everyone steals my pens
just like they steal my soul,
piece by piece, every (bleep) day.
Next, there's that one son
of a bitch who's always
trying to make everyone
feel bad with the old
passive agressive note.
"Whoever's been eating my Oreo Snack Packs
"please stop, I have low
blood sugar and I need them."
Shut up, Sharon no one
gives a gorilla's nut
about your Oreo Snack Packs.
Yeah, I ate 'em, we all
ate 'em we pass 'em around
every day, they're delicious.
You got something to say
about your Oreo Snack Packs
why don't you come say
it to my chocolate crumb
covered face instead of writing
it on a little Post-It note.
You think Abraham Lincoln
used a Post-It note
to free the slaves?
No, he didn't.
He talked about his problems
out loud like an adult.
Then, there's that one
coworker who's just always
chattin' it up on the
phone right at their desk,
right in front of everybody.
"Carol, you're never
gonna believe who I saw
"ordering the unlimited
appetizers down at the
"Thank God It's Fridays."
This is a place of
business, not the ball pit
at a Chuck E. Cheese.
There are rules here
like shut the (bleep) up.
That's rule number one.
Why don't we try following
that one right at your desk
with your little phone?
Okay, okay, can you hear me,
hear what I'm saying?
Next, there's that person that
takes work way too seriously.
Sorry I don't staple my papers at perfect
90 degree angles.
Sorry I only look at butts all
day instead of doing my job.
Sorry I got spaghetti sauce
all over the copy room
from the third time this week.
We're all just here trying
to get paid, am I right?
We're all just trying to turn hard work
into chicken nuggets, am I right?
Am I right?
So, everybody just needs
to calm the (bleep) down.
Next, there's that one shit
stain who's always late.
They're late every single
day and they always
have a different excuse.
"Sorry I'm late, I have
scratch in my throat."
That's what they say, "I
have a scratch in my throat."
We all know who was in
your throat last night.
We saw those Instagram photographs,
Jennifer.
And finally, reply all emails.
You think everybody cares
about your (bleep) opinion.
You had to send a (bleep)
email to (bleep) everybody
you (bleep) reply to
(bleep) every (bleep) person
on the (bleep) email list.
Don't you ever (bleep) hit
reply all you (bleep) heap of
(bleep) sucking, (bleep) (bleep)
munching (bleep).
All right everybody, thank
you for watching this week.
As always, you can find
our videos every week
at WhineAboutIt.tumblr.com and my page
which is Facebook.com/BuzzFeedMatt
and that's it,
that's everything.
That's why my coworkers
are pieces of shit.
Come on.
- I do everything, I type, I write memos.
I eat sandwiches, I cry in the bathroom.
That's a full day, that's my whole day.